we're in a great relationship and that's
really all you could ask for
kim kardashian has publicly supported
her husband kanye west
after he made some controversial
comments at his presidential campaign
rally over the weekend
and on twitter but now a source tells et
the couple has grown apart and are
considering divorce
at the end of the day life is about
being happy being
who you are and i feel like we are so
blessed to have
the best support system and the best
family
to really just support each other no
matter what we're going through
the source explains quote the two love
each other unconditionally but have
grown apart over the years
and it's come to a point where it might
be too far gone to save
now the source adds that they want to be
at a place where things are amicable and
easy so they can co-parent their four
children together
what does it mean to you to have this
family now kanye it's
give me a whole perspective an
understanding of what to work for
what to live for it's the best feeling
to have your own family and kids and
it's the best of course this comes after
kanye's emotional speech in south
carolina
over the weekend where he said he
considered an abortion when
kim was pregnant with their first child
north even if my wife were to divorce me
after this speech she brought north into
the world
even when i didn't want to the rapper
also posted
a string of since-deleted tweets
including one where he claimed he had
wanted a divorce
and another that alleged kim and her mom
kris jenner
were trying to take him to a hospital
i've seen him go through
a lot i always know his heart on
wednesday the skim's designer took to
her
insta story to share a lengthy message
about her husband and his battle with
bipolar disorder
asking the public to show compassion and
empathy
now a source tells et that the 43 year
old yeezy designer is refusing help from
the reality star
and her family adding that kim is giving
kanye space
because she doesn't want to upset him
but she's
reached out numerous times quote
right now a lot is in kanye's hands as
he's the one who has to face his mental
illness
and seek help in life what i've learned
is you just kind of have to go with it
a source close to kanye explains to et
that a few of his friends like music
exec
don crawley and his former manager john
monopoly
flew to wyoming to be with kanye and are
trying to get him the help that he needs
please
just make a smile the world needs some
you know we need some
some joy yeah we need a smile dave
chappelle
also visited yay on his ranch a source
told e.t the comedian wanted to be there
for his longtime pal
but fans shouldn't expect to see all of
this
play out on keeping up with the
kardashians a source close to production
tells et that kim made the choice not to
include
kanye's mental health on the show and
production is not filming his current
bipolar episode